spacex meilenstein hiv medikament das
sind zwei der highlights die ihr euch
gewünscht habt und sie kommen jetzt
herzlich willkommen markisen science
fiction material monster hat gefragt gab
es nicht mal eine meldung in der gesagt
wurde dass man bakterien gefunden hat
die plastik ohne rückstände zu ersetzen
genau das stimmt so forscher vom kyoto
institute of technology haben mir mehr
2016 einen mikroben stamm entdeckt der
biologisch nicht abbaubare eigentlich
muss man jetzt sagen plastikabfälle zu
ersetzen kann also solche abfälle wie
polyethylenterephthalat besser bekannt
als pc oder pet das bakterium idiom ella
clancys greift die abfälle mit hilfe des
enzyms plaza an das enzym gehört zur
gruppe der hydro larsen und spaltet den
kunststoff mit dem m h etage enzym glück
und tf total säure auf ethylenglykol ist
der einfachste zwei wertige alkohol und
trefft a säure ist eine in wasser schwer
aber nicht ganz unlösliche organisch
chemischen verbindung zitat der pt film
wurde stark beschädigt und war nach
sechs wochen bei 30 grad fast komplett
abgebaut die bakterien zersetzen die pc
oberfläche in einer rate von 0 13
milligramm pro quadratzentimeter und tag
75 prozent des kohlenstoffs aus dem pc
wurde zur co2 umgesetzt so die forscher
wie die experten weiter berichtet haben
kann ideeller spaniens es ausschließlich
vom pc leben entdeckt wurden die
mikroben bei der untersuchung von pt
aktuell fällen und den darauf
befindlichen bakterienstämmen die
mikrobe könne also die lösung eines
riesigen und sehr bedrohlichen problem
seien die gewinnbringende nutzung der
mikrobe ist aber noch nicht alles
pt oder pet wurde erst im jahr 1941
entwickelt die ohne scania es hat also
eine rasante leistung in der eigenen
evolution vollbracht innerhalb dieser
kurzen zeit solch effektive enzyme zu
entwickeln ist nämlich ziemlich
ungewöhnlichen anzeichen dass die
wissenschaft evolutionsprozess und
entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit zum teil
ziemlich unterschätzt das verhalten der
menschheit bräuchte auch mal ein
evolutionsforscher wir haben uns das
problem selbst geschaffen ohne eine
eigene lösung parat zu haben
ein fan erinnert sich wurde nicht ein
medikament gefunden was die hi-viren
zerstört ja und es ist noch gar nicht
mal so lange er diese ergebnisse machten
uns sprachlos
sie waren einfach erstaunlich das sind
die worte von anthony fauci vom us
national institute of allergy and
infectious dieses kurz enya idee in
bethesda ja und sie klingen emotional
berührt und sind für rund 36 millionen
menschen weltweit hoffnungsvoll
er spricht über die resultate einer im
fachmagazin ahs oder es veröffentlichten
klinischen studie über therapieansätze
im fall von immundefizienz viren zu
denen auch der hiv virus gehört an
rhesusaffen haben die forscher
sogenannte alpha 4 beta 7 antikörper
getestet
vor der einjährigen verabreichung dieser
antikörper und gängiger antiretroviralen
medikamenten infizierten forscher die
affen mit einem immundefizienz virus
genauer den semi ahnen immundefizienz
virus und tatsächlich ein jahr therapie
schien äußerst erfolgreich gewesen zu
sein
zitat wir haben guten grund zur hoffnung
dass die therapie im menschen ganz
ähnlich funktioniert es ist bekannt dass
sie s ii und hi viren sich insbesondere
in den cd4 plus t zellen in der
darmschleimhaut vermehren und eine
chronische infektion etablieren
der antikörper verhindert das einwandern
dieser immunzellen in die
darmschleimhaut eine weitere ausbreitung
der viren wird dadurch effektiv
unterbunden so lutz walter vom deutschen
primatenzentrum
wie auch gegner werden sich viele andere
an die sichere landung der space ex
rakete auf dem atlantik erinnern im
april 2016 startete das private
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex eine falcon
9 rakete vom us weltraumbahnhof cape
canaveral im us bundesstaat florida
nur zwei minuten nach ihrer abtrennung
vom rest der rakete gelang es die erste
raketenstufe sicher landen zu lassen am
8 april gegen 22 uhr 15
mitteleuropäischer sommerzeit steuerte
der untere teil der zweistufigen falcon
9 rakete die im atlantik schwimmende
fußballfeldgroße lander basis an
auf der sie kurz darauf sanft aufsetzte
zitat die erste stufe ist gelandet und
natürlich sind wir begeistert twitterte
elenas der neben spacex auch paypal
gegründet hat und ceo bei tesla motors
ist auch der us amerikanische präsident
barack obama war begeistert und schrieb
auf twitter kombat spacex on landing
rocket rcs because of nature and nasa
amerika continues to lead in space
exploration außerdem wurde auch einen
dragon raumkapsel zur international
space station iss auf dem weg gebracht
gegen mittag dockte die im durchmesser
3,7 meter große kapsel an der
raumstation an das was space ex an
diesem freitag gelungen war ist ein
riesiger fortschritt in der
weltraumfahrt hinter dem erfolg steckt
aber auch jede menge geld und der ein
oder andere fehlversuch und rückschlag
im januar 2015 zum beispiel kam es zu
einem totalverlust einer rakete des
privat raumfahrtunternehmens damals flog
die falken an rakete die landeplattform
zu schräg und viel zu schnell an die
folge war dass der 35 meter lange untere
teil der rakete mit der plattform
kollidierte und anschließend im wasser
landete anders als bei herkömmlichen
raketensystemen möchte space sechs
raketen einsetzen die mehrfach verwendet
werden können anstatt sie nach dem staat
einfach ins meer fallen zu lassen
grund dafür sind natürlich auch die
kosten die herstellungskosten für einen
falken einer kette zum beispiel belaufen
sich auf knapp 47 millionen euro der
treibstoff für die rakete ist dagegen
relativ günstig gerade einmal 105 und 7
1000 euro kostet ihren musk verglich
einen herkömmlichen raketenstart mit
einer brandneuen boeing 747 die man nach
einem flug verschrottet die
wiederverwendung von raketen könnte eine
neue ära der raumfahrt einläuten in der
flüge ins all um einiges billiger werden
und im jahr 2016
ja das sind sie auch schon billiger
geworden so jetzt aber schluss mit dem
jahr 2016 wir hoffen dass er alle gut
ins jahr 2017 rüber gerutscht seit und
wünschen euch ein frohes und
erfolgreiches ja ich würde euch jetzt
mal bitte eure wissenschafts wünsche für
das jahr 2017 in die kommentare zu
schreiben wie ich in den kommentaren
unter unserem jahresrückblicks wir ja
schon geschrieben hatte
ich freue mich zum beispiel auf die
finale meldung zum holografischen
universum ja jetzt bin ich aber mal auf
eure kommentare gespannt was glaubt ihr
was wir in 2017 entdecken oder erfinden
werden wenn euch dieses video gefallen
hat dann lass mir gerne einen daumen
nach oben und ein kostenloses abo da und
dafür übrigens einfach hier klicken wenn
er hier klickt kommt er zu einem video
der wir uns mit einer frage beschäftigen
die uns auch noch im jahr 2017 auf trab
halten wird wem gehört eigentlich das
weltall und bis dann bin ich mal sagen
bleibt dran